they were 17 of 35 from three-point
range four of those makes off the
fingertips of Our Guest gay Vincent who
is with us and you can hear us I got you
guys okay good welcome thank you
congratulations 23 tonight in game two
of the NBA finals are still fiddling
with your chair over there
we don't want to hurt Dave Vincent I'm
gonna just stand I got it y'all
he's good trying to help me out game
three from your perspective what was the
difference between game one and game two
we came to play we should have been
competing I think that was the main
difference Gabe I thought that you and
Duncan Robinson were the two stars of
the game for the Miami Heat you were a
fabulous the entire game and then when
y'all were on the ropes a little bit
Duncan came in because you were the only
one playing like you were playing great
the entire game and then when y'all were
on the ropes a little bit Duncan came in
and he was fabulous and then Jimmy made
some plays down the stretch but I want
to congratulate you because you played
well the entire game but I want to make
sure we mentioned Duncan Robin we're
talking about these stats which is so
stupid like Duncan Robinson's got a big
Minor's number I like if you know
anything about basketball Daniel
Robinson was huge in that game
absolutely absolutely it's a team effort
you know we're a team that's best when
we play together the ball moves and I
think the ball moved more tonight than
it did game one and we made plays and
Jimmy was big down the stretch how do
you guys keep a level ahead for example
in game six guys lost we would never
lost game one what do you guys do to
keep that voice yeah I mean we're
speaking back to game six it didn't
matter if we won game seven and speaking
about now we haven't done anything yet
you know we're first to four we haven't
done anything this may be our our second
trip here in the last four years but we
didn't win last time so we got nothing
to be all Jolly about yeah we got four
wins to get hey and Gabe obviously your
offense there in the second half and
that fourth quarter was was superior but
what's your defense I thought you guys
really confused them with that match-up
zone you know what were you guys trying
to accomplish defensively in that fourth
quarter against the Nuggets you know
they're very good offensive team very
well coached they run their stuff well
and so we gotta give them different
looks and that was one of the different
looks that worked out well down the
stretch tonight also seemed like you
didn't double team Nicola jokic as much
tonight as we saw in game one Wizarding
that that inserted effort coming in to
sort of let him work for his points just
a little more strategic about where we
doubled them I think you know I mean if
you just try to run at him he's way too
good of a player to do that you know he
picks you apart if you do that so we had
to be a little bit smarter think of the
game a little bit more
you know one thing that shocked me
tonight was the demon nuggets came out
flat they had to know they punched you
in the mouth last game in the heat
culture y'all gonna come out ready to
play well you're a little surprised that
y'all got off of such a great start not
at all I think game one we came out flat
and I think game two we both just came
out ready to play and we had the better
start you know game three could be a
different story but regardless we're
gonna show up ready to play and Gabe you
guys have been uh resilient and showed a
lot of grit this whole postseason the
last few days as you sort of look back
at game one and and looked at maybe the
good things and the bad things what was
the collective sort of thought process
of this team as you prepared for tonight
that game one was just one game and you
know we knew we didn't give it our best
effort we knew that we could put
together a better 48 minutes and we had
to come together and do that you know
yeah all year Denver has been
complaining about not getting in respect
and hearing the finals there or the the
every faith and everything favorite so
are you guys a little upset that you're
not getting the respect that you deserve
I speak for my whole team when I say we
don't give a damn we just want to get
four wins we're gonna give a damn about
none of the other stuff that's been a
consistent message from everybody right
that you just don't really care what all
of us are saying about it we don't care
four wins that's all that matters well
number one congratulations you started
to make this a habit brother
you start again you started getting
interviewed about us every game I like
it congratulations I appreciate it go
back to Miami and get started game three
thank you appreciate it appreciate it
congratulations thank you appreciate it
next time we'll get you a chair
appreciate you nice job Shaq he was my
mom's favorite player man she told me to
say hello all right preacher hey Mom
Gabe
here in Denver where the Miami Heat has
evened things up and swiped home court
from the Nuggets 111